We'll go ahead and get started as people trickle in.
My name is Greg Delgoff.
I am a professor of immunology at the University of
Pittsburgh. I'm joined today by Dr. Crystal Palos and Dr.
Dmitry Zhy воmarin.
We're really excited. I'm also the
incoming chair for the Cancer Immunology Working Group here at the
AACR.
And we do this every year, this Tumor Immunology for
Non-Immunologists. I'm really excited to see such a full
room of people excited about the immune system.
We're going to take some time today to go back to basics.
As immunotherapy is being more and more deployed
in cancer treatments, and we're seeing some great successes, and we're seeing some
failures,
we think it's important for everyone to really understand the basics of
the types of immunotherapy that we deploy for patients.
More importantly, we also want to debunk some myths,
some dogma. And
what we're learning is a lot of these drugs function not by the way they
were designed, and that is what we're going to be talking about today.
We made this SEM image in the lab. You
can see that T cells are really good at killing tumor cells.
There's a hype guy next to it that's just giving it
some
love. But at the end of the day, we're
not going to talk about a lot of new data from the laboratory.
I'm just going to be highlighting what we've
learned about how the immune system sees cancer.
And I'm going to be talking specifically about checkpoint blockade today.
That is PD-1 blockade for the most part.
Crystal will be discussing cellular therapies, and Dmitry will be
putting this into clinical context.
So thanks again for joining us, and we'll go ahead and get started.
I'll be talking first about checkpoint blockers.
There will be five minutes of questions.
If you have any major questions, you can talk about them after each talk.
And at the very end, we'll do a panel discussion where you guys can really
rip into us about what we got right and what we got wrong.
Okay. These are my disclosures, none of which are relevant for
today's talk, as this is mostly didactic, but important to know.
I hope this is not too pedantic to anyone
out there because we all are here studying cancer.
But of course,
why the
immune system is so important in cancer progression is
because cancer's capacity to mutate and evolve
make it a target for the immune system. Right?
But we know that just the driver mutations does not make a
cancer cell. Right? If you delete PTEN and activate BRAF in a
melanocytes, most of those cells are probably just going to senesce and die, and
only a few of them will become, ultimately,
melanoma.
And so I've got the Vogel gram up here to kind of demonstrate this fact.
But the fact is that in order to survive, these early
transformed cells in early genetic lesions need to essentially become
evolution machines. They need to proliferate, and they need to mutate.
And so the overwhelming idea that has
driven the immunology of cancer, and that's long before it was cool to study,
is that as protein coding genes mutate, their protein
products essentially become non-self.
And if we had an in vivo mechanism in the body
that allows us to differentiate self from non-self, then we'd be set.
Right? And that's the immune system. Right?
Our immune system, at the end of the day, is a mutation
detector. It is there to define and find virally infected
cells, pieces of bacteria, strange things that don't
look like us, and eliminate them. Right?
And so that's the underlying
genesis of the understanding of the immune response to cancer.
So I'm going to talk briefly about why we think this is true, and I've got
some evidence on the left, and I've got some conclusions that we can make from the
evidence on the right. So we'll go through it very briefly.
First of all, we have evidence that are histopathologic.
We actually known since the Civil War.
This is Rudolf Virchow, the father of modern pathology.
So 1863, identified the presence of leukocytes in
tumor tissue.
And we know that generally correlates with better prognosis.
This is telling us that the immune response inhibits tumor progression.
We have clinical data that immunodeficient individuals have increased incidence
of several types of cancer, which is telling us the immune system is protecting
us against tumors. And we have experimental data in animals that
immunologic memory can be induced in tumors, and that's telling
us that tumor immunity is a feature of adaptive immunity.
And so I'll talk briefly about each of these.
This is one of hundreds of different types of slides using immunohistochemistry
for various
components of the immune system. This is CD3, a marker of T cells,
CD8, a marker of killer T cells, and a macrophage marker.
And there are probably
hundreds of papers that show this very outlook, is that if you have
more CD3 positive tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes,
or TILs,
you're going to do better on most types of therapy. This is after surgery.
This was done before immunotherapy was cool.
So you can see here that having more of these TILs, this is in breast cancer, and
you can see having more TILs ultimately results in a better prognosis.
We also know that transplant recipients, individuals with primary
immunodeficiencies, are more likely to get many different types of cancer,
including skin cancers. A lot of transplant patients are told you
have to layer on the SPF 70 every time you go outside now because you're
more likely to get
basal cell carcinomas in the skin.
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma and several other cancer types can arise.
Another interesting observation is, when individuals progress
from being HIV positive to having AIDS or a secondary immunodeficiency,
several cancers can arise, including Kaposi sarcoma, which is generally a
cancer of the aged, and it was happening in young individuals
that had progressed to AIDS.And then finally, this is my favorite
experiment of all time.
You can induce
soft tissue sarcomas in mice
by giving them a DNA-damaging agent. This is a methylcholanthrene.
It's old school
cancer immunology. And it's going to create an antigenically distinct
cancer. And you can cure that mouse
by taking the tumor and surgically resecting it, because it's very local.
So you inject the
carcinogen, and then you can actually cure the mouse by just cutting off the tumor.
Now, if you take that tumor and make a line out of it and put it into a naive mouse
that's syngeneic, meaning shares the same
components of the immune system, the MHC
components of the immune system, that will grow in a naive mouse.
But the mouse that you cured, if you give the tumor back to it,
it will be rejected by the host's immune system.
So if you cure the mouse and give it the tumor back, it will have had immunologic
rejection.
Now, what's really cool about this, this is a 50-year-old experiment, by the way,
done at the NCI in the '60s.
Now, what's really interesting is that if you kill those tumor cells and make a
vaccine out of it, and immunize a syngeneic mouse, and then try to give it the
tumor,
it won't grow as well. So you can actually vaccinate the mouse against that very
tumor line and protect it. What's even cooler is if you take this mouse,
sacrifice it, and take the T cells, or just the lymphocytes at the time, they were
just using lymph node cells, and put that into this mouse, you can also protect
the mouse.
So now you may be thinking, why do we get cancer if it's a great immune system?
Well, this only matters for this particular sarcoma.
If you take a different unrelated tumor that you make by just painting that mouse
and it's going to create a different antigenic tumor, it will not protect the
mouse. It will in fact still grow this sarcoma
A if it is immunized with a sarcoma B.
So it has to be specific to that tumor.
So how does it all work? Well, here's some very brief
background on basic immunology. You make T cells, or T cells form in your thymus.
It's this butterfly-shaped gland sits at the top of your heart.
And it is the training ground for T cells.
And they make stochastic DNA rearrangements, structurally distinct
antigen receptors called T cell receptors.
And most of them die because they don't make productive protein products, but you
have something like 10 to the 13th different specificities of T cell
receptor to see these different shapes.
And it recognizes a peptide in a groove of a major
histocompatibility complex. And that's what happens.
Now, something that I've been inspired about since I was a graduate student is that
despite the fact that we go through all of this work to make an exquisitely
specific T cell receptor or T cells, the really interesting thing is that if a T
cell sees its antigen by itself, it actually turns the T cell off, not
on.
What that's in for most. Your T cells make this really beautiful T cell receptor to
see a shape. But when you trigger the T cell receptor, it actually turns the T cell
off, not on. Rather, the T cell gets a sense of context from the target through the
expression of other molecules that are seen as the T cell kisses up against its
target. It gets instructions about the nature of that
target. This is what's called co-stimulation.
Co-stimulation consists of substance molecules like CD28 and 4-1BB and
members of those families, as well as cytokines that stimulate the T cell to
proliferate or differentiate. And that is actually what gives the go signal
after the cell gets triggered through its T cell receptor.
But it's not just co-stimulation.
There's also the other side of the axis in the sense of
co-inhibition or checkpoint molecules.
These are the ones that you probably read about in The New York Times and have seen
while you're here at AACR. CTLA-4, PD-1, or suppressor
cytokines like TGF-beta. They give negative signals to the cell.
So these are traditionally called co-stimulation and co-inhibition.
T cells get context from the target.
The antigen is being expressed by a target cell, but the target cell is actually
telling the cell whether or not to stand down or to activate.
The '90s and the 2000s saw an entirely new wave of immunoregulation
of cloning these co-stimulatory and co-inhibitory molecules,
figuring out their signaling, their downstream transcriptional activity, and how
it modified the activity of the T cell.
Now, this is a massive oversimplification, but the term
co-stimulation is essentially the cell adding up
all of the
co-stimulatory
signals and subtracting out all the co-inhibitory signals and
deciding what to do at that moment.
But the key thing I want you to take away from this talk, as we're going to get a
little bit deeper into what's going on, is that it doesn't just
tell the T cell what to do today.
It also licenses long-term activity of what the T cell
might do tomorrow or next week, or what a distant
descendant of that T cell is going to do if it sees that antigen again.
That's going to be very clear to understand later.
Now, this was coined by Liping Chen,
a molecular shield that happens in cancer.
Again, the ligands for those co-stimulatory and co-inhibitory
receptors are present on either antigen-presenting cells, which
inform the T cell what to do, or on infected target
cells in the case of viral infection.
So a cell is infected, it presents a viral peptide to the T cell,
but because the cell is infected, it knows to deliver
the context that is going to tell CD28
a co-stimulatory signal to turn on, and that's going to kill the infected
cell.But tumors, through their
constant evolution and constant mutation, have
learned, and I hate to personify them, but here we are,
to upregulate the ligands for co-inhibitory molecules and down-regulate the
ligands for co-stimulatory molecules, becoming invisible,
if you will, to the immune system. The first and most prolific of these that
was discovered was called B7H1. It is now known
as PDL1 or the ligand for the PD-1 receptor.
PD-1 stands for Program Death 1, but it is a misnomer.
It has nothing to do with programmed death.
PDL1 is one of two ligands for the program death receptor, and
while PDL2 is expressed by professional antigen-presenting
cells, PDL1 can be expressed by all nucleated cells.
And a common adaptation of tumor cells is to upregulate
PDL1, which delivers the negative signal and tells the T
cell to stand down. It is
this interaction that checkpoint blockade therapy, that is anti-PD-1,
was designed to break.
And I'm going to say that again, designed to break.
Now, if we delete PDL1 on murine tumor cells, this can result in
immunologic rejection. This is work from Arlene Sharpe's group, deleting this on
everybody's favorite syngeneic cell line called MC38s, and you can see it
grows. But it's not all models. You can't delete PDL1 in every model and it gets
rejected, interestingly enough. But it's not a straightforward story.
How the tumor cell gets wise for whether or not to
upregulate PDL1 is actually the presence of the
T cell. T cells come in and they secrete gamma interferon,
a signature cytokine that activates macrophages and
turns up the commotion of what's going on.
So when T cells come in, they secrete gamma interferon, the tumor
cell senses the gamma interferon and upregulates this receptor.
So it's a response to being seen by the T cell in the
first place. And you can see that very clearly, B7H1, remember that's the
other name for PDL1, if you just give it recombinant gamma
interferon, it turns up PDL1 both at the level on the cell
surface as well as
by message.
But it's not only gamma interferon.
Things like DNA damage, hypoxia, type 1 interferons,
many other features can upregulate the expression of this ligand on
tumor cells. But this isn't just tumor cells.
Any nucleated cell, if you tickle it with gamma interferon and TNF and
other molecules, it will turn on PDL1, and thus
this is not necessarily tumor specific.
This is something that PDL1 does is to turn
off
T cells when they get hyperactive.
This has probably evolved to prevent immunopathology.
Tumor cells and stromal cells can upregulate ligands for other inhibitory
receptors. If we've learned anything from all the great minds in this room and
across this place, it's that cancer is not a one-trick pony.
PDL1 is just one cell surface ligation that they can tweak.
Now, remember what I told you earlier.
Co-stimulatory and cytokine interactions don't just license T cell functions, they
also play pivotal roles in the future functions of cells.
For instance, as I mentioned at that first slide about basic immunology, if
you just see TCR by itself, it can render T cells
anergic. This is a hyporesponsive state that prevents them from
synthesizing cytokines even if they get co-stimulation in the future.
Tumors can also induce what's called T cell exhaustion, which is another type
of hyporesponsive state that results from persistent inflammatory
stimulation when the antigen doesn't go away.
So if you see the antigen without co-stimulation, you go anergic.
If you keep seeing the antigen and you can't get rid of it, the T cell eventually
tuckers out and becomes exhausted.
Now, one might consider these differences academic. Nobody's making cytokines.
The fact is, the ability of tumors to bias T cell
differentiation to these deleterious fates underlies how
cancers form and whether or not immunotherapy is going to work.
Exhaustion is particularly important in the cancer immunity equation.
So I'm going to briefly talk about exhaustion because it's what people talk about
all the time, but people don't like to use the term exhaustion because for the
longest time, it was considered an umbrella term.
But in fact, it has a very, very distinct definition in today's
modern immunology world. This was coined
over 30 years ago in chronic viral infection. Here's the paper.
Using a
very common model pathogen called LCMV,
and you can infect mice with LCMV, and they will cure it.
They will sterilize the body of the virus, and they get memory
to it. And you can read this out, because if you acutely infect them with the
virus, and this is called chromium release assays, it's very, very
old school ways of figuring out whether or not T cells can kill targets.
And here,
in just showing you this table, you get antibodies to the virus
and you get killing if you infect the
mouse with this LCMV. However, if you infect the mouse in the
brain,
an immunologically privileged site, so that mouse cannot clear the
infection, the T cells are rendered
unable to kill their target cells, and they can't help make antibodies.
So this was called exhaustion. Now,
this is very hard to do. You have to infect the mouse in the
brain, things like that. But actually, LCMV is really interesting.
There is a second subvariant of LCMV called Clone 13,
which due to a single amino acid difference, or maybe it's two amino acid
differences, it persistently infects mice
without having to put it in the brain.
And that Clone 13 is able to induce the same degree
of T cell exhaustion, the inability to
killAnd it's dominant. If you co-infect with both the
Armstrong and the Clone 13, you still result in exhaustion.
Now, why are we going deep into this?
Well, it's important to understand the history.
So now you could use Clone 13 versus Armstrong to tell
how T cells changed, and this was done in the old days,
now a little bit older or a little bit newer.
This is with microarrays, okay, not RNA-seq, but microarrays,
identifying cell surface molecules on exhausted T cells.
And you can see right here, PD-1. Okay?
It was identified in this microarray analysis of T cells
undergoing chronic infections. As well as you may notice some of these others,
LAG-3, TIM-3, TIGIT, all these other molecules that are important.
What's also important is that costimulatory molecules are also turned on
as T cells get exhausted. 4-1BB, OX40, and GITER.
In other words,
exhausted T cells are hungry for signals.
They're looking for the environment to tell them whether or not they should get
activated or not.
So what is exhaustion? It is not strictly hyporesponsive.
It is a progressive phenotype of T cells that
lose the... So normally, T cells are kind of like Swiss Army
knives. They kill, they proliferate, and they make usually
three to 10 different cytokines per cell.
So they're making lots and lots of different instructions that change the
environment. However, exhausted T cells start to lose
the individual ability to make various
cytokines and kill.
So it's the loss of polyfunctionality that is
important. The killing ability, the multiple cytokines per cell, and the
ability to reengage in proliferative bursts.
And that's what really defines exhaustion.
It's a progressive hypofunctional lineage.
Now, here's where I really want to break some dogma.
This is beautiful data from the work of John Wherry and his lab, where they
deleted PD-1 in T cells that are going to respond to that
Clone 13 infection. Now, if PD-1 causes
exhaustion, you would think these cells would not become exhausted.
But if you delete PD-1 on T cells and then transfer them into these
infected mice, the T cells get more exhausted.
They are more dysfunctional than the wild-type T cells.
And you can see that with every other marker, with their cytokine production and so
on. What that means, they're even more severely exhausted when you
lack PD-1.
So who does PD-1 blockade affect? Because we know that PD-1 works.
So we now know that exhaustion is progressive.
It's not that you turn on and become exhausted. It happens over time.
And cancer is a disease of time. T cells take many,
many weeks, days, and months to
turn on these phenotypes. And so there are various
stages of T cell exhaustion, including some that
retain some epigenetic plasticity or
flexibility. We call these progenitor type exhausted T cells or
TPECs, and they retain some function.
In chronic infections, this is where this was originally explored, it is not
these high PD-1 expressers, which are epigenetically
committed. It is these TPECs that are actually
responding to PD-1 blockade.
Elegant adoptive transfer experiments, single-cell sequencing from human tumors,
all confirms this supposition in cancer.
Anti-PD-1 likely does not tell that really
exhausted T cell to kill its target.
Rather, it tells this TPEC cell to differentiate and
turn into an army of cytotoxic effectors.
We now know that it is not simple as T cell sees
tumor, PD-1 is ligated, you block it, T cell kills tumor.
In fact, the efficacy of PD-1 blockade requires or is enhanced
by lymph nodes, meaning the home of T cells;
DCs, so antigen-presenting cells, and their ability to make IL-12;
tertiary lymphoid structures that are nearby.
This is B cells interacting with T cells and forming
an immunologic commotion in the local area.
And the presence of CD4 T cell help.
Thus, PD-1 blockade actually induces changes in cellular
fate rather than the immediate function of the cell.
Everybody got me there?
All right, cool.
There's some clinical evidence for this to exist, as well as experimental evidence.
We've known, again, for many years, that having T cells in your tumor, that first
data slide that I showed you, is associated with improved outcomes, and that is
absolutely true for immunotherapy.
If you have more TILS in your tumor, you are more
likely to respond to immunotherapy.
However, the quality of those T cells matter.
This is beautiful data from The Lancet about 10 years ago now, is that if
you have a high proportion of exhausted T cells in your tumor,
you are more likely to be a non-responder.
So that's completely antithetical, right? When you think about it.
Exhausted T cells express the most PD-1 receptor.
However, they are not the targets of immunotherapy.
You want those less differentiated cells in your tumor.
And this is experimental data. If you take those progenitor exhausted T cells
and you put them into a new mouse and treat that mouse with immunotherapy,
it becomes exhausted by all of our metrics.
It turns on all the co-inhibitory receptors like exhausted T cells.
However, if you take terminally exhausted T cells, put them into a new animal, and
treat that mouse with immunotherapy, it stays that way. Okay?
So it's telling us the activity of this anti-PD-1 therapy targets these
less differentiated cells and tells them what to do. All right.
That was a lot to take in in one day or in 20 minutes, but I'm going to go through
briefly and I'll give you some take home messages before we have a brief
break.
Mutation and proliferation give cancer cells a platform not just to be
better cancer cells, but to also test the immune system
for immune evasion adaptations.Cancer
cells can possess intrinsic immunosuppressive traits like not
presenting antigen, losing the antigen completely,
changing cell death programs, I didn't have time to talk about that today, the
upregulation of inhibitory ligands for T cells, and the induction of T cell
anergy and exhaustion just by being there.
PD-1 signaling, if you take nothing away, I want you to take these next two points
home from today. PD-1 signaling does not cause T cell
exhaustion. It has evolved to be a brake
for preventing progenitor-like cells from becoming terminally
differentiated. So PD-1 does not cause exhaustion.
The corollary to that, PD-1 blockade does not
reverse T cell exhaustion. This gets said
all the time. We are not reversing exhaustion with PD-1 blockade.
Rather, it induces the differentiation of more memory-like T
cells into cytolytic effector T cells that kill
tumors. However, that process
exhausts them. So that's the dirty little secret.
As you add anti-PD-1 to a mouse, you're actually exhausting their
immune system, but you're hoping you kill enough tumor along the
way. What does that tell us? That tells us that
patients with a high proportion of exhausted T cells do
worse, not better on PD-1 blockade, and those individuals
that progress on immunotherapy, now what they're left with is an
exhausted tumor-specific immune response.
So you're going to have to induce new immunity in order to get those
progenitor cells that are going to respond again in a patient that has progressed
on PD-1 blockade.
Okay.
With that, I'll wrap up, and I got a minute left.
Man, I got through that pretty quick. That's great.
Happy to take five minutes of questions if anybody has anything about this basic
talk. And thank you for your attention.
It's hard to see, but I think over here. Yep.
So based on what you presented,
a patient who is truly refractory to PD-1
therapy,
can you actually overcome that somehow with
additional vaccination, hyper vaccination in some way?
Yeah. So this, I think is a huge
question and one that is being actively studied, right?
Is that you've saturated that person with
PD-1 blockade, right? And so if their tumor-specific immune response
has been essentially
driven to the endpoint. And IO,
immuno-oncology, previously has said, "Oh, let's target more co-inhibitory
receptors." And if you've been to this meeting for the last 10 years,
you know that targeting TIM-3 and targeting TIGIT haven't really borne
fruit. And that's because that immune system has
reached that exhausted state.
Vaccination is a really important thing, and that could induce
new anti-tumor immune responses, but you have to make sure that
new immune response is new. And that's why the selection
of how you're going to vaccinate the patient is extraordinarily important.
You have to go after antigens that are cryptic, that the immune system has not seen
before in order to get truly novel and new tumor-specific
immunity. Great question.
Next one over here, and then we'll go over here.
Thank you. Great talk. I love this session of immunology for dummies,
which I gratefully
came.
My question is probably I bring you back to your first slide,
or second, about the patients that
undergo immunodeficiencies,
increasing number of cancers and stuff.
But nowadays, we have a lot of antibody treatments
against rheumatoid arthritis, against TNF-alpha, IL6,
IL8, name it.
Do you have any idea if those patients have a higher rate of cancer, too, or they
are more specific and that doesn't happen?
Yeah. It depends on the type of blocker, but if you
listen to the fine print that the announcer is reading during all those
commercials, right?
Right.
That's happening at the end of a commercial.
They will say things like, "Increases in cancer risk have been shown." So
it's true, but it depends on the type of blocker.
Usually, the type 17 type blockers are less involved in this, but I
think there is some pretty decent data with TNF blockers,
that there are some types of cancer that can arise more prevalently.
Thank you.
Over here.
It's a great talk. Very inspiring.
I'm just wondering what's the difference between the T cell
co-stimulation, co-inhibition,
interaction versus like the NK cell activation or inhibition?
This is a great question. So T cells get
turned on by seeing their antigen and getting the co-stimulation
versus the co-inhibition. NK cells evolved differently.
They look
for missing self. So NK cells get turned on if they
don't see their self. So they're looking for things, because
viruses and cancer, for instance, turn off MHC, and that's what turns
NK cells off. So NK cells have itchy trigger fingers.
They're ready to kill whenever they see something weird, and they get turned off
all the time. T cells wait, and they get turned on by their
antigen.
Co-inhibition and co-stimulatory molecules are present on NK
cells, but how they interact with the NK cell machinery is still being
heavily looked at. But if, for instance, if you give
an NK cell a CAR, an antigen receptor that's got co-stimulatory
molecules on it, it'll get turned on by that.
But how that matters and what that matters for the fate of
NK cells is still under intense investigation. Great question.
Thank you very much.
Over here.
Thank you for really emphasizing that PD-1 doesn't reverse exhaustion.
Thank you.
My question is, is there anything we can do
with those truly exhausted T cells to reinvigorate the
molecular pathways or other?
Yeah. This is stellar,
right? And this is something that my lab studies quite a bit.
What can we do to get some juice out of these cells?
Because they still do some things. They still make gamma interferon.
They're still full of lytic granules.
They have potential still, but the thing is, their epigenome, they're
just like any other differentiated cell.
It's like asking a skin cell to become a,
I don't know, a liver cell, right? We're talking about differentiation here.
So if we're going to get them to reverse or to
have more potential, we have to be thinking about ways that we can
alter the epigenome or
engineer them in some other way. So cytokines and things like that aren't
necessarily going to do this because most cells can't turn back the
clock. However, there have been lots of individuals thinking about what if we take
out those exhausted T cells and we give them Yamanaka factors
to make them more stem-like. So
can we reverse exhaustion? Maybe, but I think it's going to require something
heroic rather than a simple manipulation.
And so I hope that what we've inspired all of these people to do is
think about that question and hopefully get there.
Oh, we're running... One last question.
Yeah. I just wanted to know what determines
the state of progenitor exhausted T cells versus the
terminal exhausted.
Great. Great question. So a lot of times it's time.
It can also be the degree of stress that the T cell sees.
So when T cells see antigen all the time, it never goes away,
it keeps programming the cell. So the longer it sees antigen, the more
it is going to get driven into that terminally exhausted state.
And so it's a progressive thing. You can actually model this in vitro fairly well,
and the longer you stimulate the T cells, the more terminally differentiated they
become. And so kind of immunology 101, if you open up the book,
Janeway or any other immunobiology, it'll tell you.
If the immune system sees an antigen too much, it's probably self, and so you
should probably not react to it, and so that's just encoded in our immune
system.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much for those questions.
Very, very intelligent. I'm really excited about having this conversation.
It's now my pleasure to invite up Dr. Crystal Paulos.
She's coming up
from Emory, from the Winship. She's going to tell us about a type of immunotherapy
using T cells
to attack cancer. Crystal.
Thank you for your attention, and I'm excited to talk about the power of
adoptively transferred T cells.
I think Dr. Delgoff has convinced you of the power of the immune
system. Shown in blue, these immune cells can attack a cancer cell,
shown here.
And what that really means is that
cancers have information inside them that they can
deliver to a T cell so that the T cell can recognize
it, as shown here with this really lovely diagram.
I got it from Cancer Research Institute.
More specifically, and Dr. Delgoff did a great job helping me
present this,
showing that a T cell can intimately interact with a cancer
cell. So how do they do that? I'll just remind you, I know that we just talked
about that, but these cancer cells have the ability to
process protein, chop it up into pieces, and present
it as foreign to the immune system.
And that's presented by an MHC-1 molecule, often called
HLA class I, and this peptide is then presented
to the T cell receptor.
These T cells can become activated, produce cytotoxic granules that
then can kill that cancer. But as we've said already,
cancer puts up a good fight and tries to
evade itself so that it can grow and hide from the immune system,
and it does it in a number of ways.
For example, PD-1, PD-L1 interactions, which clinically we are
fighting using checkpoint blockade therapies.
And it's an exciting time in the world of
cancer immunotherapy. Immunotherapies have transformed
the landscape of cancer care, and in fact, most of our
patients are now treated up front with therapies
like this.
Dr. Delgoff has already told you a lot about the
power of checkpoint blockade and how we can use different strategies,
PD-1 blockade, CTLA-4 blockade. There are new
therapies coming down the pipeline, like inhibiting LAG-3 and
TIM-3. Today, I'm going to tell you about the power of adoptive
immunotherapy, which is what our laboratory studies, and that's shown
on the other side of the equation with these T cells that are in yellow.
There are several forms of adoptive immunotherapy, and I'm going to walk you
through those. After that, I'm going to tell you about our own journey, where
we have found that interestingly, although cytotoxic CD8 T
cells can be leveraged to elicit these potent anti-tumor responses,
especially when they expand them to large numbers, and I'm speaking to the
billions, and then put them back into the patient, that these CD8 T cells
are quite potent. But unfortunately, as you know, some patients
don't respond or relapse after that.
We have found, interestingly, that you can program T cells down
different journeys and elicit the power of this therapy.
So this is really the conversation I want to have with you today.
What is adoptive immunotherapy?
Basic scientists, translational scientists work very closely with
surgeons and medical oncologists to get patient tissue.
For example, this is a patient where we've done surgery, and we can take the
tumor from this patient.
Once we, for example, in our laboratory, get this tumor, we can chop this
tumor up into small pieces and put it into these Petri dishes.
And we give theseInside that tumor lives lots of immune
cells, but they are suppressed by a number of factors.
We can give them the cytokine called IL-2 at high concentrations.
We call them the
T cell food. And these cytokines can
cause a proliferation of these T cells to very large numbers.
In fact, within about three to five weeks, from a small
tissue that's put into a 24-well plate, we can turn
those very few cells into 30 to 50 million
cells. These cells are then obviously cryopreserved.
In situations where patients that are more on PD-1 or
CTLA-4 therapy recur,
we use this type of therapy to treat those patients.
This is called a TIL therapy. These
reactivated T cells are cryopreserved.
We take them out of culture, and we can expand them for another
days or sometimes more. And now we're talking
about the billions of cells that are infused into these patients.
And the power of this therapy is undeniable.
And so let me show you what I mean by that.
This is a patient that has triple-negative breast cancer.
And you can see pointed with these yellow arrows, the
tumor burden that this patient is facing.
The patient's head's towards me, the feet are towards you, and this is a CAT scan.
You can really see that there's tumor
in the breast tissue, but this patient's
tumor is also metastasized to the liver.
You can see very large tumor masses.
When this cell therapy is infused into these patients, you can see
this particular patient experienced a phenomenal result.
You can see within 22 months later, this patient has actually had
a curative response, which is quite rare.
And I was very fortunate to actually meet this patient.
I trained at the National Institutes of Health a long time ago, and
Steven Rosenberg has developed this work.
He started this work in 1986. And then two years
ago, this therapy has now become FDA approved.
And why did that happen? This is a landmark paper from the "New
England Journal of Medicine" showing the power of adoptive
immunotherapy when compared to checkpoint blockade therapy.
And in this clinical trial, 84 patients per arm
were treated,
and these patients had relapsed from checkpoint blockade therapy.
The patients were either given ipilimumab, which is a CTLA-4 blocking
antibody that's been shown to be very powerful and potent in cancer patients,
to this TIL therapy that I just told you about.
And you can appreciate, very visually obvious here, that
progression-free survival at six months was drastically
different between patients that got the TIL therapy at
52.7% versus that of patients that got ipilimumab.
As a consequence of this finding,
it motivated a lot of investigators to really understand that
this is a clinically meaningful result and is now FDA approved.
Patients at the Winship Cancer Institute, for example, at Emory, get
this therapy. And this is restricted at the moment to patients
with metastatic melanoma, but coming down the pipeline will be patients treated
with head and neck cancer. And, I think, quite
honestly, the world is our oyster.
We can really start understanding how can we manipulate these TIL
therapeutic products in a way to make therapies
better. So now I'm going to walk you through
four different types of adoptive immunotherapy.
And this slide was made by my former graduate student, Aubrey Smith.
She was very talented at making these drawings
using PowerPoint. I've already told you about the first one, right?
In yellow, where we can take the tissue, the
tumor, use cytokines to expand these cells to large number.
This is TIL therapy.
Motivated by this work, it had been appreciated that some patients,
we simply can't generate a TIL product, or in
certain patients, this TIL product is not quite therapeutic.
What do we do next? We can sequence these tumors,
understand the tumor antigens and the mutations that Dr.
Delgoff talked about, and then identify T cell
receptors that recognize those specific mutations and
deliberately genetically engineer a human T cell with a TCR
instead of this bulk TIL product where we have
probably several different types of T cell responses happening because
there's polyclonal TIL products.
And this was first done at the NIH by Laura Johnson.
And what she did is take the peripheral blood of these patients,
genetically engineer the T cell receptor with a mutated
antigen against NY-ESO, and expanded them to very
large numbers and put them into patients, and saw really potent anti-tumor
responses in some of these individuals.
But there's a trick here, and one thing that the tumor
microenvironment does and what a cancer likes to do is hide
itself. And one way in which it does that, it will down-regulate
MHC. So what do you do? How do you use TIL therapy
or what we've learned about TIL therapy to make a difference in
these types of patients?
Tumors also express this protein on their cell surface.
We can detect tumor antigen in this way, too.
For example, in patients with hematological malignancies,
these malignant B cells have high levels of
CD19 on their cell surface. And so
instead of using a T cell receptor, we can generate this
human-made type of
chimeric antigen receptor instead.And
then the power of this is really good.
I will talk to you about that later.
But what happens here is we take the peripheral blood from our cancer patients.
We can genetically engineer them with a chimeric antigen receptor.
We can make several types of chimeric antigen receptor.
The binder can recognize CD19, but it can also recognize
any antigen that you, as a team, are interested in targeting.
For example, mesothelin is overexpressed on pancreatic cancer, so there are
investigators genetically engineering T cells with chimeric antigen
receptors that recognize mesothelin.
What is a chimeric antigen receptor?
We really learned a lot of lessons about antibodies and how they can bind
the surface of protein, and we can
manipulate this antibody to get the part that recognizes that
antigen. And this is called a single-chain fragment variable.
For example, we can take the
portion of this that recognizes CD19, and we can
jury-rig it in such a way that it acts like a T cell
receptor. And downstream of TCR signaling is CD3
signaling. We can also add co-stimulation. Dr.
Delgoff told you about just the TCR recognition isn't
enough. So we've learned a lot from that.
And as a consequence of that, we can add on other positive
signals that will turn on this T cell receptor, like 4-1BB, which is used in the
clinic, or CD28.
Finally,
manufacturing of T cells is quite expensive.
It can be
upwards of a half a million dollars per patient.
So one important step that we are taking
is to now
ask the question, what if you could use a universal donor, for
example, myself, take my T cells, genetically engineer them
to large numbers, and infuse them to other patients?
And there's a lot of exciting work in this category.
So this is just another way that we can think about using adoptive
immunotherapy to elicit these anti-tumor responses.
This is an example of CD19 CAR therapy doing its
job very impressively. And for example,
in this situation, the tumor has high levels of CD19 on the cell
surface, which we can target. We can genetically engineer these
CAR T cells to recognize CD19. And I just want to
really have you appreciate this particular slide.
This is a patient that has a CD19
positive leukemia, and you can see within the bone marrow,
as a stain of CD20, that there's lots of B cell
malignancies packed within this bone marrow.
After adoptive T cell transfer therapy, you can see the clearance of this
malignancy, and it's powerful and long-lasting.
You can see, if you look at the bone marrow even
177 days later, that this malignancy has cleared, and
it's made a huge difference and has also been FDA approved,
I don't know, like ten, seven years ago now? A long time.
So it's very exciting, and so we're really innovating on this work.
And I'm a big proponent of T cell manufacturing, but I do want to walk
you through how labor-intensive it is.
Just like TIL therapy,
you can see in this cartoon, we collect the peripheral blood of these
patients. We deliberately take the immune cells of choice,
usually CD3 positive T cells, expand them to large
numbers, genetically engineer them with lentiviruses or
retroviruses,
and then send these T cells back into the patient.
What is now happening, and it's very exciting, and it's really primetime news.
If you check your LinkedIn, you're hearing a lot about it.
Instead of using these manufacturing strategies, now we
can use
LNPs and viruses to in vivo engineer the T cells that
exist inside your body and bypass all of this manufacturing.
And these are really exciting times.
And in my own opinion, particularly, I think it's exciting for
patients with hematological malignancy, as well as patients with lupus and
arthritis, where B cells can elicit these
autoimmune manifestations.
I do think there's more to do, particularly when it's
in vivo engineering of
TIL, TCRs, or CARs to treat patients with
solid tumors. I think that that is going to be a bigger lift.
Why do I think that? It's purely based on what Dr.
Delgoff has already told us.
While T cells can perform and recognize a malignancy,
these T cells
over time can really become suppressed and
terminally differentiate in a way they can't perform as well anymore.
And on top of that, and we haven't talked about that a lot today, there is this
really oppressive tumor microenvironment where there
are myeloid cells, regulatory T cells, fighting against those
CD8 T cells.
And so I think that really the last part of my presentation, and I
got about 10 minutes according to this clock, is asking a question
about other ways we can intervene to elicit potent
anti-tumor responses. And by no means I'm not a fan of CD8 T cells.
I think they're quite powerful and important.
But what I'd like to talk about now is thinking about other strategies that
we can use
and target.
And so our laboratory and many others are really interested in CD4 T
cells and maybe thinking about strategies where we can take
the right type of CD4 T cells and engineer
them to be antigen specific and recognize
tumors.And not only because of themselves, but what we know
about CD4 cells is that they're the ultimate social
networkers. These CD4 T cells classically are
known to help CD8 T cells. They interface with
antigen-presenting cells. You can see in green here, this dendritic
cell, eliciting the effector functions of this
helper-like lymphocyte, then can produce IL-2 to
enhance these CD8 cells. That's not all they do, by the way.
These CD4 cells can induce NK cell proliferation, B cell
manifestations. And so we were really quite passionate about the
understanding of these CD4 cells and how to potentially marry them with
CD8 T cells.
Particularly as we move forward with this in vivo manufacturing, I think it will
be very critical to understand how we can
really manipulate the immune system,
to immediate, really potent responses against solid tumors
like pancreatic cancer.
So we wanted to ask which CD4 subset might be the most
efficacious to elicit these antitumor responses.
We turned to basic biology
hypothesizing that maybe these CD4 cells that produce interferon
gamma would be really the clutch lymphocyte
population to elicit these antitumor responses, because interferon gamma
will induce Class 1 NK cell activity.
And so really drawing in the entire immune system into that
tumor.
But there's a lot of different types of T cell subsets, and I don't even have all
of them listed. Classically, Th2 cells are
thought to be important in autoimmunity and as well as in
allergies.
While Th9 cells have been shown to be part in mucus production
and tissue inflammation. There is literature suggesting that they are potent for
antitumor immune responses, too.
And Th17 cells are thought to be the opposite, that they suppress
immune responses and cause inflammation.
And not only inflammation in cancer, but also
in autoimmune manifestations as well.
And so we were really interested in comparing these T cells
head-to-head and asking who's the winner.
And so Hannah Nockelman, who was in my lab, is an MD PhD student who's
now at Stanford, and Anna Cole really were
very passionate about this question.
And what they did is they took these CD4 cells
that already express a T cell receptor that recognizes melanoma
and programmed them down different fates.
They used high-dose IL-2, which is traditionally used in many
of the FDA-approved TIL and CAR products, and we call those Th0
cells. Or we expanded them with the Th1 strategies,
all of which are published using IL-12.
Because Th9 cells have been shown to be so potent in eliciting
antitumor responses, we used that protocol as well.
And then we used the Th17 programming strategy.
And Hannah found that when she used these strategies, they
did what we thought they would do. And so I'll just point out that the Th1 cells
produced the most interferon gamma, where these Th9 cells
produced IL-9, and these Th17 cells produced
IL-17.
And given that we had these cells in our possession and they all had the same
antigen specificity, we expanded them to the same number.
We decided to test them in one of our nastiest tumor models.
This is the B16-F10 melanoma model.
The tumor grows really fast. And so we wanted to ask the question, if we
gave a mouse this melanoma and we adoptively transferred these different
types of T cell subsets, which would be the most effective at eliciting the
antitumor responses? All the time betting on the Th1 cells.
And we were wrong. By the way, I love to be wrong.
It's really exciting to really think about how thought-provoking this can
be. So NT means no treatment. You can see that these melanoma
tumors are growing wicked fast. If you adoptively
transfer Th0 or Th9,
Th1 cells, not much difference. You do see
some pause in growth, but ultimately, these tumors also grow.
But check this out. These CD4 cells that produce
IL-17 are thought to be the bad guys in tumor immunity.
When we had them have tumor specificity, it's quite the
opposite. These T cells can start really chewing on this tumor and eliciting
these long-lasting antitumor responses.
We wondered how they worked, right?
I told you that they're the ultimate networkers with the immune system.
So we really hypothesized that they're probably drawing in CD8
T cells that can become cytotoxic.
Once a tumor is killed, it starts producing antigen.
And the host CD8 T cells in that body, we thought are starting to
wake up and start to cooperate with these Th17 cells.
And so to do that, we used bulk RNA sequencing and looked at
Th17 therapy compared to not treating these animals with the therapy.
And we found exactly kind of what we were dreaming it would be, that
within the tumor microenvironment, there was lots of MHC molecules and
interferon signals being induced, speaking to the idea that these
CD8 T cell responses would be
high on life in a way. And in the tumor-draining
lymphocytes, that's where it became interesting to us.
We found that there was lots of transcription factors are important in B cell
maturation, suggesting that maybe interestingly, the B cells might play a
role, too.
And to address this, we used these genetic strategies
where you can adoptively transfer these Th17 cells into animals that have
all of the immune cells I've just told you about that we think are important.
They have the CD8 T cells, the B cells, CD4
cells, natural killer cells. And just like we'd seen
before, these cells can really do a good job to eliciting the antitumor
responses. What if we take away the antigen-presenting cell's
ability to present that tumor antigen to the adoptively transferred T cells?
Then we start to see some bad news. You can see that these tumors are starting
to grow really rapidly.And what's surprising to me,
maybe not just based on the bulk RNA sequencing data, is that we
adoptively transferred these same T cells that are highly therapeutic
into mice that are Rag. And so these mice do not have T cells
or B cells. The therapy is totally destroyed.
Mirror imaging this bulk RNA sequencing data.
But if we put these T cells into mice that don't have CD4 cells, but they
do have B cells, check this out, the antitumor response is
very effective, curative,
implying that these B cells are really very important.
So
we wanted to know more formally if this was really the case.
All of these genetic models have their problems in that they're genetically
deficient the day they're born and cause other immune responses to happen.
And so we decided to use a different strategy.
We depleted these B cells, and when you do that,
this therapy is impaired significantly.
I'd like just you to appreciate this a little more.
If we don't treat the animal, you can see the
survival of the mice is pretty poor. The tumor grows really rapidly.
If we deplete B cells, but we don't give this therapy, same thing.
If we adoptively transfer these Th17 into these animals, the therapy's
overall pretty important. There was two mice that succumbed to this
disease, even with this potent therapy.
But if we deplete these B cells, you can see interestingly that there is
some antitumor response, but right around day 20, though, it gives up.
And that's around the time we think that these B cells are proliferating and
becoming functional. And so we think that maybe
everything is really cooperating together, that there is this direct
tumor killing, but it's not enough.
You need the inspiration of these B cells, too.
And so visually, what we can now appreciate is that if we
adoptively transfer these potent anti-tumor T cells,
that they themselves can directly bind the tumor and
kill directly. But not only that, they
communicate with B cells, cause B cells to proliferate,
become functional, and starting to become capable themselves
of producing antibodies. And then these antibodies can decorate the tumor and
elicit antitumor responses.
So what does this finding mean more globally?
I talked to you about how if we adoptively transfer CD8 T cells, it
can be quite potent and highly therapeutic.
But we're thinking about, for example, in vivo engineering, which I do think is the
future. We really want to understand the T cells to target, but also
the immune cells that we want to
deplete, like regulatory T cells and myeloid cells.
And interestingly, particularly in solid tumors, maybe we want
to keep those B cells alive and thriving and really understanding how we
can induce that response.
And so we're interested in taking these findings that we've found in mice
and turning them into clinical trials with some very key collaborators
here, particularly Greg Lesinski's in the
audience, so shout out to him. And
understanding how we can use this information to elicit potent responses
against patients with solid tumors, hoping that really we can
wake up these B cell responses as well.
I'm happy to take any questions, and thank you for your attention.
All right. We'll go ahead and take a few questions.
Also, there are a few questions online.
We will address those during the panel discussion, so please continue to put them
in if you'd like.
Over here.
Very exciting talk.
Sorry. Hi.
Thank you for a very exciting talk.
Since this is tumor immunology for dummies, I have a very
basic question.
Why is it that
CD20,
for
example, is a useful target when you need to preserve the
normal benign B cells? How is CD20
on a lymphoma cell different than CD20 on a helpful benign
B cell or other?
Oh, that's a great question, and I think it's a conundrum.
Potentially, when patients are diagnosed with a hematological
malignancy, and many of those
malignancies have CD20, so it's an obvious important target that we can elicit
antitumor responses against. But you're not wrong in that this target
will also kill healthy B cells that we
need to perform other duties in our body.
So a lot of investigators are trying to ask questions about
other targets that can be
engineered into these T cells to attack the malignancy.
For example, I didn't talk about it today, but BCMA is a very good target for
patients with multiple myelomas.
And so we really need to understand how we can manipulate
the immune system in such a way that we can preserve those
B cells, but still elicit this antitumor response.
There's a number of investigators are really looking at that question.
It's a very good question.
That was excellent. Thank you very much.
Linking these two talks, could you speak to the development
of a dysfunctional or an exhausted-like T cell state
through this progressive expansion that happens with these TIL
therapies?
Yes.
That's a great question, and I do think there's a lot of harmony
between our two talks.
This protocol that we use does
indeed tire out a T cell, right? So a
high-dose IL-2 expands T cells into this logarithmic
growth. And so
we do know through pre-clinical mouse models that the more they expand
these cells, particularly with high-dose IL-2, that these cells are
less effective per se than T cells that are
expanded to a lesser state. And many investigators are
actually now asking the questionIs there another ingredient we can add to
these T cells so that we could expand them to large numbers, but still get cells
that have these stem-like properties, these progenitor
stem-like properties that Dr. Delgoff talked about?
And there are a lot of really nifty ways one can do that.
Folks are using different cytokines, like IL-21 and IL-15 and
IL-7 together.
Investigators are also inhibiting pathways like PI3K kinase
signaling in such a way that these T cells have more stemness properties.
I know Dr. Delgoff, I was lucky to give a talk not that long ago at the University
of Pittsburgh, is using strategies to manipulate
glucose and lactate in such a way that we can make these T cells much more
therapeutic. And so, that is the beauty of the in vivo engineering
strategy too, right? You're going to genetically engineer right away these T cells
that have been gone through this manufacturing strategy.
So I think that that's an exciting world, too.
Awesome. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hi, this is Yujun from UW Medicine. Fantastic talk.
I'm curious about the T cell subset
testing separately. You said that the
TH17 may be more effective for the cancer
control, but if you test it separately, whether it will miss a
cooperative interaction across the T cells because
they will have crosstalk. What if the TH0, for
example, they may work better in the real tumor
environments, but they require TH17 exist?
So are you asking... Just sorry.
Very good question. I think I caught most of it.
Are you asking what are the differences in TH0 versus
TH17 and TH1 cells based on the type of malignancy a
patient has, and if certain immune cells could speak,
harmonize with different immune cells differently? Is that the question?
No, I'm curious whether the other kind of
TH cells, like subsets may work more
effectiveness, but they require the other kind of
subsets exist.
Yeah, I think that that's a good question.
There's a lot of investigators asking
if you could, for example, co-transfer
a TH1 with a TH17 and then maybe that empowers the
TH1 cells to be more effective. There are also studies in our
laboratory and in Dr. Luzinski's laboratory, where we're asking the question, can
we take these TH17 cells and combine them with the CD8 T
cells? Because we know that they're really effective and how they inform each
other. And I think that there's a lot of investigation really trying to understand
that still.
Sounds great. Thank you.
Thank you.
We have time for maybe one more question, and then the rest we can tackle during
the panel discussion.
Si.
Very exciting findings. My question is how do you plan to
translate into TH17 focused on therapy?
Will you
engineer all T cells then induce them to TH17 or isolate
TH17 first, then-
Yeah. We're doing all those things.
We
have two different clinical trials that
we've gotten grant funding for,
that we want to turn into a clinical trial.
And so,
in one way we're doing this, we're working with our surgeons, melanoma surgeons,
taking those tumors and using the same cytokine programming, which I
didn't list them all because there's seven different cytokines.
But we've done this. We've combined these cytokines with these TIL
products and found that they have many of the features that we found in our
preclinical mouse work.
And so one passion of ours is to
expand these T cells and put these into patients that have relapsed with checkpoint
blockade therapy. But we're also doing the other
clutch question that you asked. We are deliberately sorting
out these cells that have these qualities from the peripheral blood because there's
certain strategies you can use. You can sort them, and we're genetically
engineering them with CARs that recognize mesothelin,
so that we can then ask the question, can we target mesothelin positive
malignancies like pancreatic cancer, ovarian cancer, to elicit these anti-tumor
responses by deliberately taking these cells that we know work so well,
in hopes that what we've seen pre-clinically might be meaningful in our patients.
Thank you.
Great. Thank you, Crystal.
All right. Finally,
to anchor us here is Dr. Dmitry Zhamarin, who's now at Mount Sinai, who's
going to tell us about some of the clinical aspects of cancer
immunotherapy. Take it away.
Thank you so much, and I want to thank the organizing committee for the
invitation. So I have been tasked to put all of what you
have heard into clinical context. That's why I put on a tie today.
But, basically, I have the job of talking to
you about the potential responses and the mechanisms of resistance that we observe
as we treat the patients with these therapies, the biomarkers and
toxicity. So I'll try to cover this in the time that we have.
So here are my disclosures. None of these are relevant to the
current talk. So as Dr. Delgoff has very nicely
described, this is at the center of essentially of
what we
think is happening with the recognition of cancers of the immune system is
this model, where we have our cancers that get lysed.
They release the antigens. These are typically a set of
different types of proteins that may be recognized as foreign by the immune system.
These antigens get taken up by professional antigen-presenting cells, such as
dendritic cells. They migrate to the tumor-draining lymph nodes or other
areas where they may potentially interact with the T cells that
may have this cognate T cell receptor
thatHas to be specific for this antigenic peptide in the
context of the MHC molecule. And as Dr.
Delgoff very nicely described, that this, in the context of additional
co-stimulation that's provided by these antigen-presenting cells,
would result in a T cell activation.
These T cells would proliferate, then migrate to the tumor sites, and mediate
tumor cell lysis. And obviously, if this was always working, we would not
be standing here because we would not have cancer.
So the many parts of this process are broken, and this is where cancer
immunotherapies actually work. They essentially try to target the different
components
of this process. And,
so we can start with the tumor cell vaccines.
Essentially, these just provide additional antigen to the
patient. The goal for the tumor
vaccination is for us to essentially develop T cells
that may recognize
these vaccine antigens that may more cross-react with the cancer cells.
And essentially you have a larger pool of these cancer-specific T cells that
then can mediate tumor cell killing.
We know that vaccines by themselves don't necessarily elicit a strong enough
immune response. We have to provide them usually in the setting of
additional immunostimulatory ligands, such as
innate immune adjuvants. If you can think about
any vaccine that you're getting for an infection, usually it has some sort of
an adjuvant with it. Usually, these are a set of different small
molecules that can stimulate innate immune
system receptors, such as TLRs and STING.
These can actually be used by themselves, but the goal of these adjuvants is
essentially to stimulate antigen-presenting cells to be better
antigen presenters. We can directly use cytokines, and these
cytokines can directly stimulate antigen-presenting cells or T
cells.
You have already heard about the immune checkpoint inhibitors.
These target these negative regulatory ligands
and receptors that may be present on the surface of T cells, but may
also be present on the surface of cancer cells and
cancer-associated immune cells that provide these inhibitory signals to
the T cells.
We can use
agents like oncolytic viruses. These can mediate direct tumor
lysis, activate antigen-presenting cells, and these can also be used
to encode additional ligands or immunostimulatory molecules
that directly can stimulate T cells. And as Dr.
Paulos has very nicely described, we can bypass this entire
process by essentially taking the T cells out of the patient,
engineering them, and then flooding the system back again, with the
goal of potentially mediating cancer cell killing.
So what I want to talk to you is some of the challenges that we
encounter
while we use these agents in patients.
I have cured quite a few mice in my life, but once I started moving
into patients, we have
quickly encountered that because of the heterogeneity of the patient population,
we do encounter multiple potential mechanisms that
help them resist these types of therapies.
So what are the potential mechanisms that underlie immune
recognition and escape in cancers?
So we know that this always starts at the level of the cancer cell.
Cancer cells may have mutations. These could be single
nucleotide variations, but they could be structural variations as well.
Cancer cells may also have changes in their epigenetic states.
And combined, this may lead to signaling and
transcriptional programs that may stimulate or
inhibit the immune response. So on the level of a cancer
cell, this may mean that the cancer cell either upregulates
specific antigens, including MHC molecules, but they may also suppress
expression of the MHCs. Cancer cells may produce certain types of
cytokines and chemokines that may help to recruit
other cells to the tumor microenvironment.
And these cells may be both immunostimulatory and inhibitory.
The process becomes complicated by these cells interacting
back with the cancer cells and inducing additional programs.
And then the context matters as well, because these cancers may be present in
different organs, either in the organs that they arise, but also in
the organs that they metastasize to.
So the local tissue environment where these cancers are present can
further promote or inhibit the immune response.
And we know from emerging data that, for example, cancers that
metastasize to the liver tend to be more immunosuppressive, not
just locally, but even systemically as well.
And then even if we look within the context of a specific tumor,
these cancer cells further divide into individual clones.
Again, these could be mutational clones, but also epigenetically driven,
that further contribute to this kind of a heterogeneity where you can have even
within one tumor or multiple tumors, essentially these
populations that have distinct tumor microenvironment states.
They may have distinct T cell receptor repertoires and distinct
activities or activation states of these T cells.
How does that look in clinic? Or if we see, let's say, a patient's tumor
on a slide,
what does that mean? So
as we try to develop biomarkers to predict who are the patients
that will respond to therapy, we have learned over a number of years
to classify them into tumors which we think are going to respond, and the
tumors that we think will not are going to respond.
And as Dr. Delgoff has mentioned, this
is usually based on the basis of whether these
tumors have T cells in them or not. So on the one end of the
spectrum, we have these tumors that we call cold, and the whole
concept of cold versus hot tumors is really just
defined by the presence or absence of tumor-infiltrating
lymphocytes. So the cold tumors tend not to have any T
cells, neither in the tumor core or in the
stroma.There are multiple potential mechanisms that may lead
to the cold tumors. But in the context of what we call primary
resistance, we often think that these are the tumors that maybe never were
recognized by the immune system in the first place.
Maybe they didn't have the antigens that were strong enough to
stimulate the tumor-specific immune response, or maybe they had the
antigens, but through certain inhibitory mechanisms,
these antigens were not presented, hence the T cell priming never happened,
and these tumors are just living there by themselves without the T cells.
Next, we have what we call excluded tumors.
So these tumors may have T cells in the stroma, but not directly in
the tumor core. So these cancers may actually
have evidence of the initial T cell priming, but these T cells are
not able to make it into the tumor, and this could be driven by
multiple mechanisms. Some of these are purely
mechanical. There's
lack of permeability of your cancers to these T cells.
These could be vascular and stromal factors or presence of a very suppressive
tumor microenvironment that keeps these cells out.
So obviously, these T cells cannot mediate the tumor killing.
Next, we have the hot tumors. These are the tumors we like to have.
These tumors have T cells in the tumor. They have them in the stroma.
These T cells exhibit markers of T cell
activation, and often they exhibit markers of T cell exhaustion.
We actually like to see T cell exhaustion in the tumors, not because we
can reverse that exhaustion, but because exhaustion serves as a marker that
the T cells have made it to the tumor, they have interacted with these cancer
cells, and were able to upregulate these T cell exhaustion
machinery.
This is what we call an adaptive immune resistance.
It's essentially, again, the cancer was recognized by the immune
cells, and it adapted itself to resist
the immune response. And then finally, we get to the state that we
call edited. So in the context of this chronic
interaction with the immune cells, the cancer cells
develop further mechanisms that help them to
avoid the immune response. And these edited
tumors, they can be cold, they can be excluded, or they could be hot.
And it all depends where you catch that tumor, which state you catch the
tumor in when you are performing that tumor biopsy or the
tumor resection.
And the editing may happen if you lose the specific antigens that the immune
system recognizes.
You may lose the antigen presentation machinery or MHC
molecules, and then there are certain signaling pathways that may be downregulated
within these cancer cells, such as interferon gamma signaling.
But in the end, eventually you can get to the state of a cold tumors again,
where these are, even though the tumors originally had the
ability to be recognized by the immune system, they are no longer able
to.
So with this in mind, what are the potential biomarkers we
can use to predict who are the patients that will respond to these therapies?
And I'm mainly talking about immune checkpoint inhibitors, but this will probably
span to the other types of immunotherapies
as well. So when we talk about the determinants of immune
recognition across cancers, we broadly like to divide them
into the genetic determinants as well as an immune or the tumor
microenvironment determinants.
There are other extra determinants that may happen in our
environment as well. For example, sometimes we look at the
gut microbiome that may contribute, but ultimately all of
these impact of what is happening in the tumor.
So by genetic determinants, I may refer to the actual
germline determinants, but also, more commonly, we talk about what are
the mutations that are happening in the tumor.
So we'll look at the specific mutations that may
lead to generation of these new antigens or neoepitopes,
or potential mutations that may suppress the immune response.
Ultimately, these mutations is what leads to the tumor
immunogenicity.
Of course, the mutations by themselves, even if they produce these immunogenic
novel proteins, are not sufficient, so we'll have to look at the actual
MHC subtype of the patient as well.
And there have been a number of studies that have demonstrated that you have a
broad diversity of your MHC repertoire, you will have
a higher likelihood of presenting that antigen to the immune system.
And then on the other end of the MHC, we also have a T cell receptor,
which is what's ultimately going to recognize these antigens.
And a number of studies have also demonstrated that if you have a broad
diversity of your T cell receptor repertoire, there's a higher
likelihood that you may have a precursor T cell that would be specific
for that antigen. On the level of the tumor microenvironment, we can look
at the number of the specific immune cells
that you have in the tumor, their phenotypic states,
maybe some interactions of the cells with each other, and presence of certain
ligands that we could potentially target.
So I'm going to start with the tumor mutational burden as a biomarker because this
is one of the earliest approved biomarkers that we have had for immune
checkpoint blockade. Tumor mutational burden, as the name implies,
just measures the number of mutations that we have when we
perform certain types of sequencing.
So as you can imagine, the higher the number of mutations, the
higher is the likelihood that that tumor will produce
what we call neoepitopes or immunogenic peptides that would be then
presented through the proteasome and
processed to be presented on MHC class 1, and
sometimes MHC class 2 on the surface of cancer cells.
And there are certain cancers that have higher mutational
burden. The best example are cancers that are driven by
mismatch repair deficiency, such as...
such as certain types of colorectal and endometrial cancer.
These are the cancers that have the highest response to immune checkpoint
inhibitors. In addition to these genetic drivers,
you may also have cancers that are resulting as
a response to certain carcinogens, such as UV light in the
setting of melanoma and tobacco smoking in the setting of lung
cancer. And again, high mutational burden in these cancers has been
shown to be associated with better response.
And again, this is probably best exemplified by studies like this.
These are two randomized clinical trials of chemotherapy with
or without PD-1 inhibitors in patients with endometrial cancer.
I'm biased because I treat endometrial cancer, but this is still a good
example. At the top, you have patients with MSI high cancers.
At the bottom, you have patients that just have microsatellite stable or
low mutational burden cancers. And you can see that in these types
of cancers, this mismatch repair deficiency or high
mutational burden are strongly associated with benefit
from addition of immunotherapy, in this case, dostarlimab
or pembrolizumab. I should also point to
the fact that even though you do have a high mutational
burden, it's not predictive in 100% of cases.
And in both cases, there's still about 30% of the patients that do not
respond to these therapies. But this is certainly a good
start. So if we cannot predict this on the basis of
genetics alone, again, we'll like to look at the tumor microenvironment,
because this is essentially where the immune response is
happening. When we look at the tumor microenvironment, we can of course
look at the T cell numbers and their location.
Are they in the tumors or are they extracellular?
Again, as what I have called before, hot tumors versus cold
tumors. But this is a very non-specific measure,
just because many of these T cells were actually found not to be tumor specific.
Just because you have a T cell in the tumor doesn't mean it's recognizing your
tumor. And in fact, many viral specific T cells, such as the ones
that are maybe recognizing Epstein-Barr virus or
CMV or influenza, can be found in the tumors.
What we'd like to look at is actual T cell phenotypes, because certain
phenotypes like activated T cells or dysfunctional T cells
are an actual evidence that these T cells have encountered an antigen in the
tumor and have upregulated these programs.
We can also look at the tumor microenvironment phenotypes such as expression of
certain ligands like PD-L1.
And increasingly, we're not just looking at these markers in
isolation. What we'd like to look at is at the interaction between these different
cells in the tumor microenvironment.
So PD-L1 expression is probably one of the most commonly
used biomarkers because it is an approved biomarker in clinic for
certain cancer types. This is an example of a study in lung
cancer demonstrating how selection of patients by
PD-L1 expression can help to identify the patients that are
more likely to benefit
from drugs like pembrolizumab, which is a PD-1 inhibitor.
And in this case, using the
PD-L1 expression score of 50% or
above, we can readily identify the patients who may benefit from
this therapy, and in fact, FDA used this biomarker as an
approval. But this is probably one of the best examples where this biomarker
works. I can honestly tell you that in the majority of the
cancers, PD-L1 actually either doesn't work or
it doesn't result in such a broad differential.
So what else can we look at? So we have to look
beyond PD-L1. And again, this is an example where
we're looking at the other cells in the microenvironment and their interactions
with other cells can be useful.
So again, as Dr. Delgoff has mentioned, we can look at the
presence of dysfunctional T cells or early dysfunctional T
cells in the tumor
microenvironment, and we can define them by presence of certain markers
that are expressed on the surface.
Again, these cells don't exist in isolation.
We can look at potentially in proximity of whether these cells
exist
close to other cancer cells or immune cells in the
microenvironment that are expressing PD-L1. Why is that important?
Well, as Dr. Delgoff has mentioned,
normally if you have the T cells that are recognizing tumor antigens, they will
produce interferon gamma. This interferon gamma will bind to interferon
gamma receptor on cancer cells or immune cells, and that's what leads to
PD-L1 upregulation. So we know that the distance of interferon
gamma action is approximately 30 to 50 microns.
So if we look even in a static tumor and
measure the interaction between the T cells and these
PD-L1 positive cancer cells on immune cells, this can
be used as a surrogate marker that this T cell is active or
it has been active in the past. And we
can use these kinds of measurements to actually predict, again, whether the patient
is more or less likely to benefit from the immunotherapy just on the basis of
presence of these cells and their interaction with
the other cells in the microenvironment.
And again, this is an example of a study that we did demonstrating that just
presence of these PD-1 positive cells in a tumor microenvironment,
but more importantly, their proximity with other
PD-L1 expressing cells can be predictive of clinical benefit, in
this case, in endometrial cancer.
But there are other kinds of interactions we can measure
as well. And again, the more we learn about the biology
of our tumors, the more things we can look at. Again, Dr.
Paulus has highlighted the importance of CD4
cells, which mayHave been underappreciated before.
Well, there are a couple of very nice studies.
One is from Andrea Schietinger's group,
and this one is from Miriam Merad's group, demonstrating that a
presence of interactions with other cells in the tumor
microenvironment, in this case, the triads between dendritic cells,
CD4 T cells, and CD8 T cells,
is what's probably most predictive of responses to immunotherapy, in
this case, in the hepatocellular carcinoma, and on the bottom to
malignant mesothelioma,
or in the context of adaptive cell therapies.
And there's beautiful biology that goes into this to demonstrate how the CD4 T
cells provide the help to the CD8 T cells to license them and
reprogram them to become functional.
So again, the more we'll learn about the biology, the more markers we could
potentially use. But
what I want to highlight is that if we want to translate these kinds of markers to
patients, it's not necessarily that difficult.
When we do these kinds of analysis, we start very broad, but we can usually narrow
them down to two or three markers that can be implemented in a
routine clinical IHC-based types of assays.
Lastly, we can also look at the T cell receptor repertoires
from these patients, as they can also offer clues into the specificity of
the immune response. If you just
sequence your T cell receptor repertoires, you usually don't know what those T
cells may be recognizing. But emergently,
we can look at patterns of these T cell receptors based on
the sequence, but also on their sharing between the different tumor sites or
on their sharing between the blood and the tumor.
And if we see, for example, if we have tumor-infiltrating T cells
that are expanding in peripheral blood in response to therapy, sometimes we
can use this as a surrogate marker of systemic anti-tumor immune
response. And here is an example of such a study.
This was published by Dr. Kai Wucherpfennig's group a few years ago.
This was in the setting of a clinical trial of patients with head and neck
cancer that got immune checkpoint inhibitors before they got the
tumor resection. Essentially, they identified
tumor-infiltrating T cell
repertoires, and then looked at them within the peripheral blood
in response to therapy. And what they observed is that in the patients who are
more likely to respond to immunotherapy, these
tumor-resident T cells were more
likely to expand in the blood of these patients, again,
suggesting that this could be a potential good measurement of systemic
anti-tumor activity. I have three minutes left, so I'm going to use
that to cover the immunotherapy toxicities.
So nothing is free. So many of the therapies that we use
come with certain risks. So starting with immune checkpoint
inhibitors, we do get these, what we call
immune-related adverse events or IRAEs.
And this is because activation of immune system is not perfect.
And then so these immune-related adverse events result from inappropriate
recognition of normal tissues by T cells, and this can lead to these
autoimmune-like tissue destruction.
In most of the cases, it is very mild, but in some cases it's not.
So early recognition of this is
essential. These T cells may affect essentially any
organ in the body, but we know that there are certain organs that are more affected
than others.
Different classes of checkpoint inhibitors are associated with different
toxicities, but any immune-related adverse event can occur
with any agent. And it's very important to distinguish them from
other causes, especially infectious causes or underlying disease.
Again, as I mentioned, most of these toxicities are very manageable,
but some are associated with significant morbidity
and even mortality. So, for example, if you look at the
study that was published now seven years ago or eight years ago,
just looking at the number of cases and fatality rates that you get from certain
immune checkpoint inhibitors, you can see that certain
toxicities, such as myocarditis, can be quite
substantial and even lethal. Close to 40% of the patients that
develop myocarditis, which is inflammation in the heart, can die from
this therapy. How do we usually treat immune-related adverse
events? It all depends on the severity.
Mild cases can just be followed. The patients with moderate
symptoms usually require some steroids.
But then patients with more severe symptoms typically need to
be admitted to the hospital, get systemic intravenous steroids, and
potentially other immunomodulatory antibodies as well.
Adaptive cell therapies are associated with their own set of immune
toxicities. One of the types of toxicities we can look at is the
tissue damage that can result from on-target, off-tumor
effect, basically recognition of shared antigens on normal
tissues. Dr. Paules did mention that some of these adaptive cell
therapies, such as targeting B cell malignancies, will effectively
eliminate your normal B cells as well.
So that's an example. The more common things that we observe are what we call
cytokine release syndrome. This is a systemic inflammatory reaction that can be
caused by inflammatory factors that are released by these activated
immune cells. This is a systemic response.
You can also have a response,
which is neurologic. It's called ICANS or immune effector cell-associated
neurotoxicity syndrome. It is mediated by a different mechanism.
It's not exactly clear of how it happens, but it has been suggested to
be mediated by the direct immune-mediated damage or
secreted inflammatory mediators.
And again, identification of this is highly important
because they are treatable if you find them early enough.
And I'm going to stop there and take any questions. Yeah.
So,
due to the robust discussions, we are now at 11:30.
I think that if people are willing to hang out and
participate in the panel, perhaps we can handle your questions as well during the
panel discussion. I've also done my best for those folks online to answer their
questions through the online platform.
But please feel free to ask any questions remaining.
They'll probably kick us out of here in 10 minutes or so.
So, over here.
Okay. Thank you. That was a great presentation.
So I'm a clinical immunologist, and I have a question, very
clinical perspective. So
in the first talk, you talked about how some of the primary immune
deficiencies present with cancer.
So from a clinical perspective, if you're dealing with a
patient with inborn errors of immunity who develops
cancer as part of their phenotype, and you have an immunotherapy
available for treatment of their cancer,
what is the landscape for that small group of
patients? Do you think they'll have more trouble with the
side effects of immunotherapies, they'll benefit more?
So I'm really interested to know what's your perspective and if
you've had any personal experience with patients like
that.
So your question is basically, can we use these immunotherapies in the patients
with potentially underlying autoimmune diseases?
That is correct.
Yeah. So,
it's a challenging question often to answer in clinic.
I think it depends on the severity of the
autoimmune disease and the potential to cause
significant harm. So for example, if a patient has a history
of arthritis but has been off systemic autoimmune
therapy for a year or a couple of years, and we know that the
risk of the cancer progression is much worse for their health, these are the
patients that we often would say, "You know what?
Let's try an immune checkpoint inhibitor and see if it works." But then there are
some of these types of autoimmune diseases where
we know we can kill a patient. Like a patient with myasthenia gravis, there have
been reports that they have got immune checkpoint inhibitors, and
they stop breathing because the diaphragm no longer works.
So I think this all has to be taken in the context of the
severity of their ongoing disease and the potential
to cause harm. There are some patients to whom we don't give
checkpoint inhibitors. Patient who had a transplant, for example, and is
receiving suppressive therapy to maintain their
kidney is a good example. Do we
risk the patient losing the kidney but have their cancer progress, or do we
just give them
another type of therapy? So it's all patient specific, and this takes very
extensive discussion with them.
That's great. If I may, I'm just going to reframe my question.
So my question was more specific to patients with immune system
defects, not per se autoimmune. So
you talked about how the microenvironment of the tumor with the
collaboration of the dendritic cells, B cells
and all that can affect the
immunotherapy and how the patient responds.
So if you're dealing with an
immunodeficient person, do you expect that their
response to immunotherapy will be different
from a person who does not have a baseline defect in their immune
system?
That's an excellent question. So I think that depends also on the degree of immune
deficiency. Most data that we have is actually in patients with HIV.
So the patients with HIV who have the
virus controlled, let's say they're receiving the antiretroviral therapy,
the data suggests that they respond just almost as well to
immunotherapy as other patients.
But I guess it all depends on the type of dysfunction.
We also know that patients with primary immunodeficiencies that might not have as
many T cells are probably less likely to respond. Yeah.
Okay, great. Thank you.
Over here.
So T cell engagers have been remarkably effective in hematological
malignancies, but in solid tumors, except for a few
exceptions, they have not been so successful.
I'm curious what your thoughts are on what we need to do to improve T cell engager
efficacy in solid tumors,
even setting aside dirty, clean antigens.
Is it an immunologic problem? Is it a co-stem problem? Is it something else?
Yeah. I would say that,
and this was a question that was also raised online as well, in heme malignancies,
the target is, in general, a professional antigen-presenting cell.
Right?
CD3 is probably enough to get that cell to get activated and to
kill that liquid tumor. In the case of solid tumors, again,
clean and dirty antigens notwithstanding, the lack of co-stimulation is going to be
a critical component of this. And so an engager platform that
includes a co-stimulatory molecule or some other co-therapy would likely be
more effective.
Yeah, really wonderful talks. My question is for Dr. Paules.
So I was specifically curious about the mechanism involving TH17s
directly recognizing MHC-II-expressing melanomas.
So how would you say this changes with MHC-II low or MHC-II
negative melanomas? And kind of related to that, how important is
interferon gamma mediated upregulation of MHC-II on
these cancers in order to potentiate the response?
Yeah, both are great questions.
Pawel Muranski has
worked in this same model for quite a long time, and
he's inhibited the interferon gamma pathway,
either just with an antibody or using genetic models,
and the therapy is completely destroyed.So
these Th17 cells can become plastic.
They convert to type 1 cells. I always have found it
fascinating that the Th1 cells also produce a lot interferon gamma, but doesn't
really matter. The Th17 cells have more than that.
They
stick around longer, they have persistence, et cetera.
In terms of Class 2, it's a great question.
So
Pavel has also knocked out Class 2 in B16
specifically, and also other investigators, not
him, but have blocked MHC II with antibodies, and that
also impairs the antitumor response, implying that
the direct killing is important. Our laboratory has compared the Th17
cells that aren't antigen specific,
compared to those that are. And if they're not antigen
specific, but to have these Th17 properties, that's not enough.
There has to be antigen specificity.
Okay, thank you. Great. We'll go to this side.
Yeah. Thank you for the session. The focus on the T cell
exhaustion, you have explained really well
and exhausted
the importance of this. But
last talk mentioned briefly the biomarkers of this T cell
exhaustion with the interferon gamma distance.
What other biomarkers do we know, or what work is being
done to try to infer proxies for this
T cell exhaustion throughout the patient journey?
Yeah, this is a really great question because the biomarkers that currently exist
are the ligands, right? We look for PD-L1, we look for tumor mutational burden.
But we don't really look at the immunologic status of the
patient. This is something that is a massive unmet need in my personal
opinion, is that we don't really have good techniques because it's not something
you can just do IHC for. Where you're looking for
how exhaustible is a patient immune system and what
status is it at, at the time of diagnosis.
So it's a huge question. It's a really good one.
Unfortunately, I do not have a satisfying answer for you.
Maybe I can also add. I think part of it is
also we're often limited in what we can do, right?
If I could get a patient just like a mouse, and I can get their fresh
tumor and look at the T cells and peripheral blood in the tumor, single-cell
RNA seq, whatever, it's great, but we're often not able to do
that. You can do a biopsy on the patient.
You get this 18-gauge tiny piece of tissue that you're not even sure whether it
represents the whole tumor or not.
Fortunately, with evolution of the techniques that we have, we're now able
to do a lot more, even from this formalin tissue than we were able to do
even a few years ago with the spatial transcriptomics, which will
hopefully continue to improve and give us a deeper resolution.
Even using these static types of samples, we will hopefully be able to
predict that. But we're not there.
But I would always encourage that within the context of any clinical trial,
we have to get the tissue.
Okay, so in the interest of time, and they are going to kick us out pretty soon,
let's just do two more questions, and then the rest of us, we can handle this
offline. I'll hang out. I guess you guys will probably hang out, too.
All right, go ahead, please.
Hi. I'm a pediatric oncologist. And
while it's rare, we've been asked about using or
considering using immune checkpoint inhibitors in some infants.
There's not great data or really any data on patients who
are under six months old and are still in the process
of establishing tolerance and dependent on
antibodies from breast milk or their mom that has stuck around.
Can you comment on things that we may be either wary about
or reassuring towards using checkpoint
inhibitors in infants?
That's a great question. Pediatric immunology is something that is understudied.
So not even just pediatric oncology, but pediatric immunology is something that has
been lesser studied, although it is
of growing interest. And I think our lack of basic understanding of what would
happen with sledgehammer type approaches like checkpoint blockade in
an infant population could set up long-term loss of tolerance.
It's a great question. I think Dmitry, do you have any?
I was going to say the best evidence I can offer you is that most of the mice we
use in the lab are six-week-old mice, which are kind of pediatric, right?
And those are the ones that we use for all of our therapies.
But
obviously in the long term, we have no idea what you could do
to a pediatric patient. Is a six-week-old mouse the
same as a six-month-old infant? I don't know, right?
But
only time will show. If you have any data, please share.
We're all through. Okay. In the interest of time, we'll take things offline.
Thank you so much.